Speaker 1: Yesterday, there was some very
interesting hearings in Washington, D.C.,
sort of primarily about the Janet what happened
on January 6th.
And a little bit later, we're going to get
to the comments from Donald Trump's former
acting secretary of defense about when Donald
Trump finally did say, OK, let's bring in
the National Guard to clean up what's going
on on January 6th.
We'll get to that later.
But one of the really interesting I don't
know if we would call it a side story.
It's really kind of a main story that came
out yesterday during the testimony is that
the Biden administration's top law enforcement
officials, including Merrick Garland, the
attorney general, including Homeland Security
Secretary Mayorkas and a number of others,
they said in no uncertain terms that white
supremacists are the greatest domestic terrorist
threat within the United States.
Now, if you've been watching my show for a
while or if you're familiar with the data
on domestic terrorism, this would not be a
surprise to you.
The story that the right has been telling
for a very long time is that American Muslims
or immigrants from Muslim countries, even
left wing ecoterrorists in some versions of
the story, are really the great domestic threat.
But when you look at the data and you look
at domestic extremism incidents, you very
quickly understand that the biggest threat
in the United States indeed, is white supremacists,
which sometimes overlap with these sort of
patriot and sovereign citizen antigovernment
type movements.
That's really where the bulk of the threat
comes from.
And Merrick Garland said yesterday to lawmakers,
quote, Domestic violent extremists pose an
elevated threat in twenty twenty one and in.
The FBI's view, the top domestic violent extremist
threat we face comes from racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists, specifically
those who advocate for the superiority of
the white race.
Now, what you are also starting to see is
that Republicans are having to find a new
way to even talk about this.
And Senator Richard Shelby, for example, instead
of focusing on the level of threat, is trying
to make the administration seemed biased in
its priorities.
And when it was Richard Shelby's turn to talk
to Merrick Garland, he asked, are you investigating,
for example, the protests in Portland, Oregon,
with the same vigor that you're investigating
what happened on January 6th?
The implication and wrapped up in that is
the implication and the assumption that the
Portland protests were left wing violence,
whereas I guess he sort of may be conceding
that the January 6th riots were right wing
violence.
And Merrick Garland responded very well and
said, quote, We don't care what the ideology
is.
Violations of law are pursued and are prosecuted.
I think it's fair to say that in my career
as a judge and in law enforcement, I have
not seen a more dangerous threat to democracy
than the invasion of the Capitol.
That doesn't mean we don't focus on other
threats as well.
And so we we are starting to see this kind
of shift among the right, where it's becoming
essentially undeniable that the bulk of the
incidents are these right wing patriot, sovereign
citizen, anti-government and certainly white
supremacist, racially, ethnically, religiously
motivated events.
But what Republicans are now kind of going
back to and it's good that they're having
to change what they're saying, even though
it's still bogus, is OK.
Well, maybe these are the numbers, but what
about the attention that's being paid?
There are political decisions that are being
made about who to investigate, who to charge,
et cetera.
And that should be and that should be looked
into.
But it's sort of like a welcome to our world
moment.
This is what many of us have been saying about
the judicial justice system for a very, very
long time.
When you look at who actually does drugs,
has drugs, deals, drugs versus who is prosecuted,
who is policed, what are the sentences that
are given out?
We've been pointing out that there's a lack
of equity there for a very long time along
racial lines for sure, among class lines as
well as we've discussed.
So now unable to continue denying the empirical
reality of where the greatest number of threats
come from, they are pushed back to having
to make an argument the left has been making
about the justice system for a very long time.
I don't know where this will go, but yesterday's
hearings were very interesting because they
touched on a lot of these different tangential
topics.
They're big topics, but tangential to the
to the day of January 6th, including investigative
priorities for federal law enforcement, including
what the biggest threats are.
And a little bit later in the show, we will
get to some of the testimony about the nitty
gritty of what happened on January 6th.
Send me your thoughts on this.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And remember that on Monday, Memorial Day,
it's not this Monday, it's not the next Monday.
I think it's the one after that Monday, Memorial
Day.
We're doing a one day membership special single
day membership bomb.
If you've been thinking home and maybe maybe
I'll sign up someday.
Memorial Day is the day to do it because it
will be a beautiful discount.
If you want to be notified on Memorial Day,
just get on my newsletter at David Pakman
Dotcom.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is an
audience funded program primarily, and
you can sign up today at Join Pakman dot com.
You'll get The Daily Bonus Show as well as
the commercial free audio and video streams
of the show.
The members only newsletter, occasional invites
to members only town halls.
There's a lot there.
Grab one of those memberships that join Pakman
Dotcom.